we all feel the weight of the shadows on
our future but in another time every bit
as ominous as our own there were those
who could see away through the darkness
to find a star to steer by Carl Sagan
wrote I was a child in a time of hope I
wanted to be a scientist from my
earliest school days the crystallizing
moment came when I first caught on that
the stars are mighty Suns
when it first dawned on me how
staggeringly far away they must be to
appear as mere points of light in the
sky I'm not sure I even knew the meaning
of the word science then but I wanted
somehow to immerse myself in all that
grandeur I was gripped by the splendor
of the universe transfixed by the
prospect of understanding how things
really work of helping to uncover deep
mysteries of exploring new worlds maybe
even literally
it has been my good fortune to have had
that dream in part fulfilled
for me the romance of science remains as
appealing and new as it was on that day
when I was shown the wonders of the 1939
New York World's Fair
[Music]
[Applause]
this is where the future became a place
but how could there be hope in 1939 the
angriest voices had taken the world
stage preaching hatred and tribal
division the most cataclysmic war in
history which would take the lives of 16
million human beings that was only just
beginning yet even as darkness descended
it was possible to awaken the young Carl
Sagan and his contemporaries with a
thrilling vision of the future one that
was powerful enough to inspire many of
them to do the years of hard work
required to become scientists and
engineers
[Music]
[Applause]
the miracle of television became a
reality to the public at the 1939
World's Fair we had learned to
manipulate electrons into what would
become of civilization altering force
this working Marvel of TV set was
transparently to convince the skeptics
that what they were seeing was not just
motion picture images the images on the
television screen were actually live
signals from across time and space a
possible world revolutionary high
technology was first glimpsed here
[Music]
[Music]